that was so nice
thank you thank you oh my goodness thank
you this is such an honor to be here oh
my God I am so so nice and by the way
what a nice introduction it's like we
feel successful thank you as as you
should because okay so you might be like
the female version of the man I've
dreamed about my whole life I love a
comedian
I love someone who's a prolific writer
how do you manage the process of
retaining capturing noticing and then
putting it out into these projects of
yours that might that must be the most
lyrical description of the most
unglamorous group of people in the world
writers I know I love it I absolutely
love it I mean when people talk about
Comedians and writers they usually think
of like unfashionable slobs so like on
behalf of all writers like thank you for
saying that and some of them are like
some of them you know some writers rooms
are not like always the sexiest group of
people and yet yeah I think they are
like all of the crushes I've ever had
are basically like funny talk show
writer League comedian man why is that
gone for you would you say
curious I've been single for seven years
as have I so
um so we know not to go down that path
but although I was on a date once
ironically and BJ Novak sat down and I
remember thinking oh I wish I was on a
date with him he's so attractive why is
he not with Mindy Kaling I want to be
with Minnie Kaylee why are they not
together
wait wait couple things your first
reaction was wow he's so attractive he's
going to be so excited about that but I
think I dream of you being like the
ultimate couple because you seem like
best friends and you're just so both so
wonderful he is a wonderful friend and
he's the Godparent of both my kids and
he loves children and is um they're so
attached to him he's really part of our
family but we've known each other for a
long long time and I think anyone who's
been friends with someone for 18 19
years and at one point dated and now it
doesn't like they maybe understand this
I mean you have exes that you wouldn't
necessarily marry now right I actually
have finally finished with all my exes I
know no no I now know it the book is
closed on all of them yeah and I think
I've closed the book with a lot of them
on this show
wait am I gonna get confronted here I
know okay sorry to God
um but thank you for saying that and
about about the writing I mean I just I
don't know like I'm just a real homebody
I stay at my home I do all my writing in
my bed and it's such a nice I spent so
much time in front of the camera as much
you might know and that's really
wonderful but has its challenges I do
like being behind the scenes and I love
doing things in my own clothes with no
hair and makeup I really love that part
of it when it's time to get in front of
the camera ironically it becomes less
and less comfortable I'm much more happy
and like a scrunchie in my sweatpants
yes if we were both in our sweatpants
and scrunchies right now we could be in
our sweatpants it might be a little bit
less fun for the audience and the
audience at home but it is fun to dress
up and play the part but like how do you
I wonder because again I'm so in love
with you and I sort of wish we could be
a couple
um what when you're looking around in
life do you see someone say something
and think that would make a great piece
of dialogue or do you come up with the
dialogue on your own like how do you do
it that's a great question about where
inspiration comes from and I think where
my inspiration comes from I mean when I
was in the office it was so much about
people you see in line at the DMV and
like any kind of like Larry davidy
bureaucratic interactions you have with
people and that would go into the show
like what would Michael Scott do what
would someone who like Dwight who was
obsessed with rules like what would they
do but on my shows now never have I ever
and the sex lives of a college girl my
favorite you know they all came here I'm
obsessed they were so cute on the show
thank you for having them it's such a
good time thank you that was like I
loved watching that I love that show I
think also what your writing is is it's
so Universal you know it's there's
there's a lack of an age too because you
can and I don't think that I believe in
age it's not the first thing I ask
somebody because there their life
experiences could lead them to Great
maturity or immaturity so the number's
not going to totally reflect and when
you watch something you know of the
younger characters or the college girls
I'm going to be 48 I am in I am wrapped
you write so universally that like age
or timing or place doesn't come into it
it's more about what human beings go
through that's so kind I mean I have to
give so much of the credit my co-creator
Justin Noble my other co-creator Lang
Fisher we really made an effort to fill
our writing stops with like young people
young women who are close to the age of
the characters in the show and like even
my assistant Kate it's like when I'm
writing dialogue I'm just like hearing
how she talks and then just being like
okay this is how the character would
talk not like a boomer like me so I I
think paying attention to like actually
people who are close to that age I don't
know I came up in this age where
do you know those people when you're
like getting I don't know when you were
young the older people who are like
young people or this and that and
they're so entitled and everything and I
have to check myself because I'm 43 to
not be that way and to really listen to
Young people and by the way sometimes I
do want to be like shut up you're so
annoying you're so annoying and entitled
but what I've learned is that they're
they're just such a font of knowledge
and they're all such young activists and
I really am inspired by them all the
time and they drive me crazy and it's
like for the past couple years working
with them has been hugely informative
and good for having a daughter I think I
and I've met your daughter yet and I
just love her she loved your house our
daughters have played together kit and
Olive and Frankie due to our mutual
friend yes and I was like I'm one step
closer to Mindy I've got her daughter in
my house which sounds so creepy but I
just I just think that you have put so
many wonderful things into the world I
think that you have this brand that is
funny and Whimsical and Charming it's
true to the way we feel our
awkwardnesses our triumphs our
vulnerabilities but true like you've
been like like I said a movie that I
watched when I was in college we all
went to the theater to go see Charlie's
Angels and I know that you've produced
so many movies you've directed so many
things and it's like to make the
transition from actor to director and
producer is tough especially we're not
talking about three years ago we're
talking about you know 15 20 years ago
and seeing things like that and see
people can be multi-hyphenates they give
people like me courage that I can do the
same thing all I want to do is be with
you Charlie's Angels for Charlie's Angel
five I don't know we're in Three okay
listen
I could get a traitor
we need to talk
I would love to hear like what you think
are Charlie's Angels three would be and
then like go make it happen what a dream
I mean
this guy anyway I dream I'm like let's
call Cameron and Lucy and make this
happen
um all right you've got another
incredible project that I want to talk
about Mindy's book studio and the very
first book that you've selected to bring
here today also is the vibrant gear such
a good book yes I would love to tell you
about this
um
so I was raised on books you know my
parents are immigrants so we didn't like
I was a latchkey kid they both worked
and so I was just raised reading books
like alone in my room
um and wasn't allowed to watch a lot of
TV when I was really little and so I it
they became so important to me and
um later as I started writing my own
books I've written three books I know
you've written books so um it's it's
such a great way I'm a really social
person I love being around people but I
really do I really do love writing and
this medium that I want to learn so much
about in fiction in particular uh I've
really put in a pedestal I think if you
can write fiction if you can write a
novel you're brain is just is just on
another level and so the mission of
Mindy's book Studio which is an imprint
of Amazon publishing I'm so lucky to be
working with them because of their reach
I was going to say that will reach
people I know it's so incredible is is
really simple it's just to give a
platform to female writers that are
underrepresented some who are more
established some that are emerging and
the first book Is this amazing book The
vibrant years by sonali Dev and sonali
Dev I am honored to say is the beautiful
woman who is sitting right here in our
audience
thank you so much for coming here today
may I ask like what the process was for
you writing the book getting together
with Mindy how has it been I have to
start with saying I tell all my friends
that I've just had a baby with Mindy
Kaling that's what I like to tell my
friends understood a book baby got it
I'm in my relationships with a lot of
women well this is a takeaway promising
for me then good that's her superpower
but this was everything I've ever wanted
to say about being a woman and the main
protagonist is a 65 year old hot grandma
and so I think this idea that women
become less as they age is so flawed and
wrong and that's what we see in fiction
and we see in the media but we really
become more and I kind of wanted to talk
about that but it is basically three
generations of Indian American women on
the modern dating scene together well I
cannot wait to read it and I love
what you say because you're so right the
500 years is available now and we have
to cut to a quick commercial break I
don't want to we're going to get into
red flag yellow flag green flag I want
to know everything you think about
dating all right after the break we'll
be right back
[Music]